dos enteros positivos difieren por 60 la
suma de sus raíces cuadradas es la raíz
cuadrada de un entero positivo que no es
un cuadrado perfecto ok creo que el
enunciado es un poquito complicado vamos
a irlo desmenuzando vamos a irlo
separando por pedazos para entenderlo
muy bien nos dice dos enteros positivos
difieren por 60 eso quiere decir que si
tenemos por ejemplo a y b son dos
enteros positivos y estos son enteros
enteros
entonces nos dice que su diferencia a
menos b es 60
esto inmediatamente nos está diciendo
que a no es otra cosa si sumamos por
ejemplo b de ambos lados nos dice que
esto es b más 60 ok entonces esto es
esta primera parte después nos dice la
suma de sus raíces cuadradas es la raíz
cuadrada de un entero positivo que no es
un cuadrado perfecto entonces la suma de
sus raíces
esto sería raíz de a
más la raíz de b es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de un entero positivo esa es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de un entero
positivo entonces se es entero pero nos
dice que no es un cuadrado perfecto como
no es un cuadrado perfecto quiere decir
que la raíz de ese no es entero
no es entero
muy bien ahí lo tenemos entonces vamos a
ver nos piden calcular cuál es el máximo
valor posible para la suma de los dos
enteros entonces queremos maximizar a +
b para eso está esta expresión de aquí
parece un poco complicada entonces para
simplificar la y para obtener muchísima
información del problema vamos a elevar
de ambos lados al cuadrado aquí vamos a
elevar al cuadrado y aquí también
entonces si desarrollamos este cuadrado
tenemos raíz de a al cuadrado es a más
dos veces raíz de a por raíz de b que es
la raíz de ave más raíz de b al cuadrado
que es b debe ser igual hace muy bien
entonces aquí es en donde vamos a
obtener mucha información porque vamos a
ver algo muy importante de el producto
de ahí b entonces fíjense muy bien que a
es entero
también ve es entero entero y se también
es entero muy bien entonces fíjense que
estoy sumando un entero y un entero más
otra cosa me debe dar un entero entonces
necesariamente esto de aquí dos veces la
raíz de ave debe ser entero muy bien
pero más aún
yo lo que afirmo es que la raíz cuadrada
de a por b es un entero y fíjense muy
bien porque si como como dos veces la
raíz de a por b es entero entonces dos
veces la raíz de ave es igual a un
número que es que se enteró muy bien
entonces esto es entero ahora bien quién
sería la raíz cuadrada de a por b la
raíz cuadrada de a por b es igual acá
entre 2 y aquí es en donde vamos a hacer
este siguiente truco imagínense por un
momento que la raíz cuadrada de a por b
no es entero quiere decir entonces para
que esto ocurra
a la hora de dividir k entre 2 esto no
se enteró quiere decir que acá tiene que
ser impar es decir que no sea múltiplo
de 2 verdad de esta forma esto sería un
número racional una fracción ok entonces
si elevamos ahora al cuadrado si
elevamos al cuadrado de ambos lados
tenemos a por d es igual a k cuadrada
entre 4 entonces acá cuadrada como caerá
un impar entonces acá cuadrada sigue
siendo impar muy bien sigue siendo impar
pero a este número impar lo divido entre
4 y esto por supuesto como es impar y al
dividirlo entre 4
esto no es entero esto no es entero pero
tenemos un problema porque esto era
igual a x b y a por b es un entero es el
producto de dos enteros entonces aquí
hubo algo que no funcionó y fue suponer
que la cadena impar es decir que la raíz
de a por b
no era entero entonces raíz de a por b
es un entero eso es lo que estamos
concluyendo estamos concluyendo que la
raíz cuadrada de a por b tiene que ser
un entero tiene que ser tiene que ser un
entero y vamos a repasar tantito que fue
lo que dijimos dijimos si suponemos que
la raíz cuadrada de a por b no es entero
entonces resulta que queda por b no es
entero y eso claramente si era entonces
lo que estuvo mal fue decir que la raíz
de a por b no era entero entonces como
la raíz de acorde tiene que ser un
entero esto significa también que si
elevamos al cuadrado entonces la raíz
perdón la raíz estamos elevando al
cuadrado entonces a por d tiene que ser
es es un cuadrado perfecto
es un cuadrado
perfecto es un cuadrado perfecto muy
bien entonces que significa que sea un
cuadrado perfecto quiere decir que la
multiplicación de a por b es un número
entero al cuadrado muy bien entonces si
si tienes a a sabemos que es b más 60
entonces b más 60 si al al multiplicarlo
por b debe ser un cuadrado perfecto esto
es un n cuadrada donde n es entero
ok otra vez estamos jugando con puros
enteros entonces si desarrollamos aquí
tenemos b por vez de cuadrada más 60 b y
aquí voy a dejar un espacio ahorita te
digo para que y esto debe ser n cuadrada
ahora en este espacio lo dejé porque en
este momento lo que voy a hacer es
completar el trinomio cuadrado perfecto
entonces tengo que ver que que constante
sumarle para que esto sea un trinomio
cuadrado perfecto
y esto simplemente sale de dividir 60
entre 2 que son 30 y elevarlo al
cuadrado que son 900 entonces para que
esta igualdad se preserven yo agrego 900
y se los restó el detalle es que ahora
yo voy a poder agrupar esto de aquí y
esto de aquí me queda como ve más 30 al
cuadrado verdad si si tienes dudas de
cómo como completar trinomios cuadrados
perfectos consulta las listas están en
quizás en la lista de álgebra
seguramente muy bien entonces ahora
a esto le restó 900 que es lo que queda
aquí y esto debe ser igual a n cuadrada
muy bien entonces qué es lo que voy a
hacer ahora lo que voy a hacer ahora es
lo siguiente voy a restar n cuadrada de
ambos lados n cuadrada de ambos lados y
sumar a 900
de ambos lados
entonces sumamos 900 y restamos
encuadrada lo que consigo es esto se
cancela y esto se cancela y lo que tengo
ahora es al sumar lo que tengo b más 30
al cuadrado - n cuadrada y esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados eso era lo que
yo quería conseguir con este con estas
operaciones
esto me debe dar 900 muy bien entonces
como factor hizo una diferencia de
cuadrados pues es de más 30 más n por ve
más 30 menos en verdad y esto debe ser
900 muy bien entonces la diferencia de
cuadrados se factorizar de esa forma
simplemente sumas las dos raíces de cada
uno y luego multiplicas por este menos
la raíz de este que es justamente lo que
hicimos en este paso entonces fijémonos
muy bien en lo siguiente todo esto son
números enteros de más 30 más en es
entero de más 30 menos n
pero me debe dar perdón novecientos
entonces tengo un producto de dos
números que me da 900 y además fíjense
en lo siguiente que ve más 30 más n si
le sumamos ve más 30 menos en esto nos
debe dar 2 b más 60 que por supuesto
esto de aquí es par entonces dos números
que sumados me dan par quiere decir que
ambos son pares o ambos son impares muy
bien pero por otro lado el producto de
dos números es que es 900 que es un
número par este es para este producto el
producto
el producto es par entonces si un
producto de dos números es park quiere
decir que al menos uno de ellos es par
pero ambos serán pares o ambos serán
impares quiere decir entonces
concluyendo que este es par y este
también es par muy bien entonces con
esto lo que hemos conseguido es que
ahora basta con analizar qué factores de
900 son ambos pares muy bien y ver que
coincidan con todas las restricciones y
todas las observaciones que hemos hecho
hasta este momento ese es nuestro
objetivo ahora y ver cuál es la ve más
grande para obtener lo que queremos
fíjense que si nosotros más maximizamos
ve inmediatamente como a sven más 60
entonces también va a estar maximizado y
por lo tanto la suma va a estar
maximizada así que vamos a encontrar
cuál es la vez más grande que satisface
esto
vamos a ver y nos vamos a ir analizando
los factores de 900 entonces en
principio uno podría decir ah bueno
tenemos uno y 900 pero este queda
descartado porque ambos tienen que ser
pares verdad entonces uno podría decir
bueno que tal dos y 450 estos dos son
factores de 900 y es bueno que al
multiplicarse dan 900 ambos son pares
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa vamos a ver
qué pasa porque ven más 30 más n debe
ser 450 450 y ve más 30 - n debe ser
igual a 2 entonces si nosotros sumamos
nos quedan 2 b más 60 esto se cancela
nos quedan 400 52 y entonces 2 b
restamos 60 de ambos lados tenemos 2 b
es 452 menos 60 son 392
ahora si dividimos de ambos lados entre
dos nos queda que ve es 102 2 por 1 son
2 llevo unas 196 muy bien entonces ve
son 196 vamos a ver entonces esto ya me
está diciendo quienes ve simplemente
ahora decimos que si b es 196 entonces
sería 196 más 60 que son 256 y sabemos
que la raíz cuadrada de a más la raíz
cuadrada de bbb tiene que ser un número
que no se enteró entonces la raíz
cuadrada de a es ok es la raíz cuadrada
de 256 más la raíz cuadrada de 196 la
raíz de 256 son 16 la raíz de 196 son 14
y esto está muy bonito porque nos dio
que la suma de las raíces es 30 pero
mucho cuidado y hay que tener muy buena
muy buena vista y muy buena
y tener muy buena memoria de qué era lo
que queríamos obtener la suma de las
raíces cuadradas debe dar un número raíz
de c que no sea entero y aquí obtuvimos
1 que si es entero entonces para b igual
a 196 perdón para de igual a 196 y igual
a 256 cumple todo excepto que es la suma
de las raíces cuadradas no es más bien
si es un número entero y no lo queremos
entero así que esto es inmediatamente
hay que descartarlos muy bien entonces
tendremos que seguir por ejemplo qué tal
si tomamos el 3 entonces sería 3 por 300
nos da 900 pero éste tampoco podemos
elegirlo porque ambos tienen que ser
pares que tal 4 si tomamos 44 x
serían 4 por 225 nos da 900 pero otra
vez no son ambos pares si nos vamos con
el 5 bueno no importa cuál sea el otro
factor 5 no es par entonces vamos con el
6 el 6 por ciento 50 nos da 900 entonces
vamos a ver si quizás esto funciona
vamos a ver
6% 50 entonces se debe cumplir que ve
más 30 más en es 150 y que ve más 30 -
cn es 6 muy bien entonces si nosotros
sumamos nos quedan 2 b más 60 estos
nuevamente se cancelan nos debe dar 156
y si restamos 60 de ambos lados nos
queda que 2 b es igual a 96 si restamos
60 restamos 50 y luego 10 y entonces si
dividimos entre 2 nos queda que b es
igual a 48 48 muy bien entonces si ves
48 a 60 más que éste entonces son 108
108 y quién es la raíz de 108 la raíz de
108 más la raíz de 48
vamos a ver raíz de 108 es por ejemplo
podemos factorizar un 44 por 2 son ocho
y llevamos dos y nos quedan es 4 por 27
pero a 27 le podemos factorizar 9 y nos
queda 3 verdad es 9 por 3 por 4 entonces
esto nos queda dos por tres que son 6
raíz de 3 más
ahora raíz de 48 cuanto es 48 le podemos
factorizar 8 por ejemplo no nos conviene
es es 3 veces 16 esto es 3 veces 16 y la
raíz de 16 es 4 entonces tenemos 4 raíz
de 3 y esto nos queda simplemente 10
veces la raíz de 3 y esto está muy bien
esto está muy bien porque esta suma nos
dio algo que no es entero este número no
es entero entonces
uno podría decir que este es un muy buen
candidato y de hecho es el mejor
candidato que podemos tener si nos damos
cuenta a medida que vayamos avanzando
los la diferencia entre estos factores
se va apareciendo cada vez más quiere
decir que a la hora de hacer esto a la
hora de hacer esto
vamos a obtener veces cada vez más
chicas entonces te invito a que hagas el
ejercicio que te comienzas tú mismo de
que si si continúas bueno 7 no
funcionaría verdad pero 8 por no no sé
cuánto sea pero pero si tú hicieras el
resto entonces vas a darte cuenta que ve
cada vez tiene que ser mucho más pequeño
entonces dan la respuesta óptima para be
es esta cuando los dos factores son 6 y
150 nos da que b tiene que ser b tiene
que ser 48 ya tiene que ser 108 esta es
la respuesta a este problema y bueno en
realidad la respuesta es para la suma
verdad entonces
es igual a 108 48 que esto es 156